the Netherlands Germany Spain and now
France more and more Ebola cases have
surfaced in Europe on Wednesday the
World Health Organization briefed MEP s
on latest measures to halt the epidemic
the risk of the spread in Europe is very
low because we have stronger systems the
EU has already spent 800 million euros
on prevention and treatment since the
outbreak in March but she said much more
is needed one thing that you can do is
to try to mobilize more medical teams
and medical professionals to go there
and solve the issue of the of their
treatment and medical evacuation out on
the heels of the e used carbon cutting
and energy efficiency agreement last
week members of Parliament's Environment
Committee have agreed on a text designed
to reduce the ill effects of climate
change it's quite an ambitious document
which realizes the urgent need of action
a step in the right direction but for
many greens not nearly enough that's a
view shared by the head of the UN's
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change during a visit to Parliament
earlier this week it's very important
for us to start on the path of
mitigation and that can be done through
energy efficiency greater use of
renewables nuclear stopping
deforestation expanding afforestation
preparations for next year's global
climate talks in Paris kickoff in Lima
Peru in December
slices of cake all round marking the
30th anniversary of Parliament's women's
rights and gender equality committee but
has it led to greater slices of power
hemos avanzado pero todavía que de un
camino para correr importante es este un
abreeza salad aisle in sustainable la
unión europea assist a una lokra social
como es la violencia de janeiro donde
las mujeres son asus eee nadas here here
to that said many women MPs from the
Middle East visiting the European
Parliament to discuss deteriorating
conditions for women after the Arab
Spring in some countries with peaceful
demonstrations the woman can get their
rights but with the military calculated
actors are the men and this is makes the
homeless come back and down and down